[Music]
are you
ready for the most merry mission of the
year blitzen
what sprinkles get down
i need help
no no no no no no no no santa
sprinkle's call came in from up ahead
follow me
looks like someone's staying on the
naughty list
larry light him up ho ho ho you ugly
mother
larry you son of a [ __ ]
[Music]
sprinkles you're bleeding i ain't got
time to bleed
happy holidays you filthy animals
oh oh holy sh
maybe we have a word let me guess he's
done something crazy
[Music]
show me again i want to break your neck
to the looney bus nebraska williams
that's coyle
that's lynch with merch why are you here
i don't think you believe me
come on man
the [ __ ] was that that's the thing that
killed my men
aliens
weakness attracts its prey like a game
seems to enjoy it that's not a predator
that's a sports hunter well we took a
vote predator's cooler right
[ __ ] yeah do you have a plan
x sniper with ptsd and a team that's
mental
you're insane right gentlemen
they're large they're fast and [ __ ]
you ups their idea of tourism
figured something out i think we're
gonna die
just pointing it out my big boy's a
hunter
he brought his dogs with him
the predator
[Music]
you